una ceremonia sobria y breve es lo que
nos habían advertido desde el palacio
del inicio y así fue porque se trataba
de la investidura de un segundo mandato
un presidente así ocurrió también con
françois mitterrand y con jacques chirac
el presidente manuel macrón también nos
habían advertido iba a ser un discurso
dividido en dos partes la primera
explicar por qué los franceses eligieron
y lo segundo decir lo que va a hacer en
este nuevo gobierno efectivamente macrón
dijo que vivimos una época de grandes
crisis la guerra la pandemia la crisis
climática y que a diferencia de otros
países donde las personas han elegido
replegarse en sí misma y optado por los
nacionalismos aquí en francia dijo de
los franceses optaron por un proyecto de
futuro republicano y europeo y pasó a
enumerar las prioridades de su nuevo
gobierno justamente con esta idea que ya
dijo el pasado 24 de abril de que este
no es la continuidad de su anterior
mandato sino que un gobierno nuevo el
repitió muchas veces la palabra actuar y
nombró esas prioridades salud educación
y juventud acción climática hacer de
france una potencia agrícola científica
e industrial en fin todas las que serán
sus prioridades la democracia superar la
desigualdad unir a los franceses y
terminó diciendo actuar sin descanso y
la brújula para mí será servir a mi
patria además haciendo un guiño al nuevo
nombre de su partido renacimiento dijo
que todo este actuar es el fundamento de
este renacimiento democrático de francia
la ceremonia terminó con la revista a
las tropas para mostrar también que él
es el primer comandante y jefe de las
fuerzas armadas francesas con la
marsellesa y esos 21 cañonazos lanzados
desde la explanada de los inválidos